all right good morning let's get started
so today you see the support vector
machine algorithm and this is one of my
favorite algorithms because it's very
turnkey classification problem so in
particular talk a bit more about the
optimization problem you have to solve
in support vector machine then talk
about something called the representor
theorem and this would be a key idea to
how will work in potentially very high
dimensional like 100,000 dimensional or
a moving dimensional or 100 billion
dimensional or even infinite dimensional
feature spaces and just to teach you how
to represent feature vectors and how to
represent parameters that may be you
know hundred billion dimensional or 100
trillion dimensional or infinite
dimensional and based on this we derived
kernels which is the mechanism for
working these incredibly high
dimensional feature spaces and then
hopefully time permitting wrap up with a
few examples of compute implementations
of these ideas so to recap on last
Wednesday we started to talk about the
optimal margin the classifier which said
that even the data set that looks like
this then you want to find the decision
boundary with the greatest possible
geometric margin right so the geometric
margin can be calculated by this formula
and this is just the derivations in
lecture notes just you know measuring
the distance to the nearest point and
for now let's assume the data can be
separated by a straight line and so
gamma I is this is sort of geometry I
guess derivation the lecture notes this
is the formula for computing the
distance from the example X I Y I to the
decision boundary governed by the
parameters W and B and gamma is the
worst case geometric margin right you
will make so
of all of your M training examples which
one has the resource possible geometric
margin and the support that the optimal
margin classifier will try to make this
as big as possible and by the way what
will what you see later on is that
optimum Archana classifiers BC this
algorithm and okto margin classifier
plus kernels meaning AC take this idea
of the pie in a hundred billion
dimensional feature space that's the
support vector machine ok um so I saw
one thing I didn't have time to talk
about on Wednesday was the derivation of
this classification problem so whether
this optimization objective come from so
let me let me just go over that very
briefly so the way motivated these
definitions was said that given training
set you want to find the decision
boundary parametrized by W and B that
maximizes the geometric margin right and
so again as we can your classifier
output G equals W transpose X plus B and
so you want to find parameters W be
they'll define the decision boundary
when your classification switch from
positive and negative that maximizes the
geometric margin and so one way to pose
this as an optimization problem is let's
see is to try to find the biggest
possible value of gamma subject to that
subject to that the geometric margin
must be greater than equal to gamma
right so so in this optimization problem
the parameters you get to fiddle with
our gamma W and B and if you solve this
optimization problem then you are
finding the values of W and B that
defines a straight line that defines the
decision boundary so that so this
constraint says that every example right
so this constraint says every example
has Joe mentioned margin greater than
equal to gamma this is this is what is
saying and you want to set gamma as big
as possible which means that you're
maximizing the worst-case geometric
logic this make sense so so if I so the
only way to make gamma say 17 or 20 or
whatever is if every training example
has geometric margin bigger than 17
right and so this optimization problem
is trying to find Delvian be to drive up
gamma as big as possible and have every
example have geometric margin even
bigger than camera so this optimization
problem maximizes the it causes your
causes your defined Delta NP with as big
a geometric margin as possible eyes
bigger the worst case your magic margin
as possible okay and so does this
defense actually yeah right okay
actually raise your hand if this makes
sense oh okay well many of you all right
I mean this even a slightly different
way um so let's see of a few training
examples you know in the training
examples geometric margins are 17 2 & 5
right then the Jamaican margin in this
case is the worst case value 2 right and
so if you are solving an optimization
problem where I want every example where
I wanted the
where I want a min over I of gamma I to
be as big as possible
one way to enforce this is to say they
can
I must be bigger than equal to camera
for every possible value of I and then
I'm gonna lift camera up as much as
possible right because the only way to
live camera up subject to this is it
every verb value of gamma is bigger than
that and so lifting gamma up maximizing
gamma as effective maximizing the worst
case examples geometric margin which is
which is which is how we've defined this
optimization okay and then the last one
step to turn this problem into this one
on the left is this interesting
observation that you might remember when
we talked about the functional margin
which is the numerator here that you
know the function margin you can scale W
and B by any number and the decision
boundary stays the same and so you know
if if your classifier is y so this is G
of W transpose X plus B right so if if W
was the vector 2 1 let's say that's the
classifier right then you can take W and
B and multiply it by any number you want
I can multiply this by 10 and this the
point it's the same straight line right
so if I take a look I think let's see
with this 2 1 X this actually defines
the decision boundary that looks like
that if this is X 1 and this is X 2 then
this is the equation of the straight
line where the V transpose X plus B
equals 0 right that's 1 & 2 you could
verify for yourself you plug in this
point then W transpose X plus B equals 0
we plug at this point there because it
was x equals 0 and so that's the
decision boundary
where the SVM will predict positive
everywhere here and predict negative
everywhere to the lower left and this
straight line you know stays the same
you very much supply these parameters by
any constant okay and so to simplify
this notice that you could choose
anything you want for the normal W right
just by scaling this by a factor of ten
you can increase it or scale me by a
factor one over ten you can decrease it
but you have to flexibility to scale the
parameters W and B you know up or down
by any fixed constant without changing
the decision boundary and so the trick
to simplify this equation under that one
is if you choose to scale the normal W
to be equal to 1 over gamma because if
you do that then this optimization
objective becomes
maximize one of the norm of W subject to
right if you substitute normal W equals
one of Yama and so that cancels out and
so you end up with this optimization
problem instead of maximizing one of a
norm W to minimize one half the normal W
squared subject to this okay and so
that's a rough I know I did this
relatively quickly again as usual the
full derivation is redundant lecture
notes but hopefully this gives you a
flavor for why if you solve this
optimization problem and you're
minimizing over W and B that you are
solving for the parameters WMV that give
you the optimal margin classifier okay
now Delta margin classifier we've been
deriving this algorithm as if you know
the features X I let's see
we're from deriving these algorithm is
if the features X I are some reasonable
dimensional feature X equals r2 it's a
100 or something um what we will talk
about later is a case where the features
X I become you know 100 trillion
dimensional right or infinite
dimensional and what what we will assume
is that W can be represented as a sum as
a linear combination of the training
examples
so um in order to the writers for vector
machine we're going to make an
additional restriction that the
parameters W can be expressed as a
linear combination of the training
examples right so and it turns out that
when X I is you know 100 trillion
dimensional doing this will let us
derive algorithms that work even in
these hundred trillion or in these
infinite dimensional feature spaces now
I'm describing this just as an
assumption it turns out that there's a
theorem called the represented theorem
that shows that you can make this
assumption without losing any
performance the proof the represented
theorem is quite complicated I don't
want to do this in this class there's
actually written out the proof but why
you can make this assumption is also
written election else is pretty long and
involve proof involving a primal dual
optimization I don't to present the
whole proof here but there give you a
flavor for why this is a reasonable
assumption to make okay oh and just just
to make things complicated
later on we actually do this right so
why I is always plus minus one so so
we're actually by convention we're going
to assume that
WI can be written all right so in this
example this is plus minus 1 right so
this makes some of the math a little bit
down so you come out easier but this is
still saying that W is can be
represented as a linear combination of
the training examples ok so um let me
just describe less formally why this is
a reasonable assumption but it's
actually not an assumption that
represents a theorem proves that you
know this is just true at the optimal
value of W but let me convey a couple
ways why this is a reasonable thing to
do I see yes
so um maybe his intuition number one and
I'm going to refer to logistic
regression
right we're suppose that you run
logistic regression with gradient
descent say so cost appear in descent
then you will initialize the parameters
to be equal to zero at first and then
for each iteration of stochastic
gradient descent right you would update
theta gets updated as theta minus a
learning rate times you know times X
okay and so sorry here alpha is a
learning rate
nothing does overload the notation this
alpha is nothing to do that alpha but so
they're saying that on every iteration
you're updating the parameters theta as
a by adding or subtracting some constant
times some training example and so kind
of proof by induction right if they
tostop zero and on every iteration a
great descent you're adding a multiple
of some training example then no matter
how many iterations you run gradient
descent theta is still a linear
combination of your training examples
okay and again identical stay there that
it was really theta 0 theta 1 up to
theta n right whereas here we have a B
and then w1 down to W I know this pens
really bad if you like alright yeah
throw these away so they don't keep
haunting us in the future ok right so
but if you but so I did those a theta
rather than chop you but it turns out if
you work through the algebra this is a
little fruit by induction that you know
as you run logistic regression after
every iteration the parameters theta of
the parameters W are always a linear
combination of the training samples and
this is also true of you use batch
gradient descent if you use factory in
the Senate then the up a roux is this
and so it turns out you can derive
gradient descent for the support vector
machine learning algorithm as well you
can derive your descent authorized W
subject to this and you could have a
proof by induction you know that no
matter how many iterations you run
through in descent it will always be a
linear combination of the training
examples so that's one intuition for how
you might see that assuming W is a
linear combination of the training
examples you know is a reasonable
assumption I want to present a second
set of intuitions and this one would be
easier if you're good at visualizing
high dimensional spaces I guess but let
me just give intuition number two which
is um let's see so so first of all let's
take our example just now right let's
say that the classifier uses this 2 1 X
minus 2 right so this is W and this is
um then it turns out that the decision
boundary is this where this is 1 and
this is 2 and it turns out that the
vector W is always at 90 degrees to the
decision boundary right this is a
effective I guess geometry or something
well then the algebra right where it's
the vector W to 1 so the vector W you
know is sort of two to the right and
then one up is always that well all
right the vector W is always 90 degrees
to the decision boundary and it doesn't
bounce separates where you predict
positive from where you predict negative
okay and so it it turns out that if you
have to take a simple example let's say
you have two
training examples a positive example and
a negative example right then is next to
the linear algebra way of saying this is
that the vector W lies in the span of
the training examples oh and and and the
way to picture this is that W sets the
direction of the decision boundary and
as you vary B then the position so the
relative position you know setting
different values of B will move the
decision boundary back and forth like
this and W pins the direction and just
one last example for for why this might
be true is so we're gonna be working in
very very high dimensional feature
spaces for this example let's say you
have three features x1 x2 x3 right and
then later we'll get to where this is
like a hundred trillion right and let's
say for the sake of illustration that
all of your examples line the plane of
x1 and x2 so let's say X 3 is equal to 0
ok so let's say from all of your
training examples X 3 equals 0 then the
decision boundary you know will be will
be some sort of vertical plane that
looks like this right so this is going
to be the plane specifying W transpose X
plus B equals 0 where now W and X are
three dimensional and so the vector W
will have a should have W 3 equals 0
right if one of the features is always 0
was always fixed then you know W 3
should be equal to 0 and that's another
way of saying that the vector W you know
should be represented as an in the span
of just two features and clinics
span of the training examples okay all
right I'm not sure if either intuition
one or intuition to convince this you I
think hopefully that's good enough but
this the second intuition will be easier
if you're used to thinking about baptism
high damaged all feature spaces and
again the formal proof of this result
which is called the represent two
theorem is given in the lecture notes
but is a very possessive well no it was
actually there's actually on the most
complicated is well it's definitely the
high end in terms of complexity of the
of the full derivation of the formal
derivation is this result so so let's
assume that W can be written as follows
so optimization problem was this you
want to solve for W and B so that the
norm of W squared is as small as
possible and so that do this is the one
for every value of I so let's see
normal W squared this is just equal to W
transpose W and so if you plug in this
definition of W you know into these
equations you have as the optimization
objective min of 1/2 sum from I equals 1
through m so this is W transpose W
which is equal to I guess some of I some
of AJ of my ELF ej y iy j and then X I
transpose XJ and I'm going to take this
so this is an inner product between X I
XJ and I'm gonna use I'm just only write
to this this right X I did this notation
so X comma Z equals X transpose Z is the
inner product between two vectors this
is maybe another alternative notation
for writing inner products and when we
derived kernels you see that expressing
your algorithm in terms of inner
products between features X this is the
key map practical step needed to derive
kernels and we'll use this slightly
different so open angle bracket closing
angle brackets notation to denote the
end the inner product between two
different feature vectors so that is the
optimization objective oh and then this
constraint it becomes something else I
guess this becomes a what is it why I
times W which is transpose X plus B is
greater than one and again this
simplifies or if you just multiply this
out
so just to make sure the mapping is
clear all these pens are like dying all
right so that becomes this and this
becomes that okay and the key property
we're going to use is that if you look
at these two equations in terms of how
we pose the optimization problem the
only place that the feature vectors
appears is in this inner product and it
turns out when we talked about the
kernel trick when we talked about the
application of kernels it turns out that
if you can compute this very efficiently
that's when you can get away with
manipulating even infinite dimensional
feature vectors well we'll get to this
in a second but the reason we want to
write the whole algorithm in terms of
inner products is there'll be important
cases where the feature vectors are
hundred trillion dimensional but you can
compute it or even infinite dimensional
but you can compute the inner product
very efficiently without needing to loop
over you know the 100 trillion elements
in an array right and we'll see exactly
how to do that later in very shortly
so all right now it turns out that we've
now expressed the whole optimization
algorithm in terms of these parameters
alpha right defined here and B so now
the parameters theta
well now the parameters need to optimize
for our alpha it turns out that by
convention in a way that you see support
vector machines refer to you know in
research papers or in text books it
turns out there's a further
simplification of that optimization
problem which is that you can simplify
to this and the derivation to go from
that to this is again relatively
complicated but it turns out you can
further simplify the authorization
problem I wrote there to this and again
you can copy this down if you want but
it's also written the lecture notes and
by convention this slightly simplified
version optimization problem is called
the dual optimization problem the way to
simplify that authorisations problem to
this one that's actually done by using
convex optimization theory and and again
the derivation is written in lecture
notes but I don't want to do that here
if you want think of it as doing a bunch
more algebra to simplify that problem to
this one and cause density you can still
be along the way there's a little more
complicated than that but but write full
derivation is given in the lecture notes
and so finally you know the way you
train for the way you make a prediction
right as you solve the Alpha rice and
maybe for B right so you solve this
optimization problem or that
optimization problem for the Alpha rice
and then to make a prediction
you need to compute H of W B of X for a
new test example which is G of W
transpose X plus B right but because of
the definition of W dub this is equal to
G of that's W transpose X plus B because
this is W and so that's equal to G of
sum over I of I in a product between X
and X plus B and so once again you know
once you have stored the alphas in your
computer memory you can make predictions
using just inner products again right so
the entire algorithm both the
optimization objective you need to do
during training as was how you make
predictions is is expressed only in
terms of inner products so
we're now ready to apply kernels and
sometimes in machine learning people
sometimes we call this a kernel trick
and then we just the other recipe for
what this means
step one is write your algorithm in
terms of X I XJ in terms of inner
products and instead of carrying the
superscript you know X I XJ I'm
sometimes gonna write in the product
between X and Z right where X and z are
supposed to be proxy is for two
different training examples exam thanks
Jay but it simplifies a notation or
write a little bit to let there be some
mapping from your original input
features X to some higher damage though
set of features Phi and so one example
would be lets you try to predict housing
prices a particular house will be sold
in the next month so maybe X in this
case is the size of the house or maybe
is size in yeah right maybe X is the
size of a house and so you could take
this 1d feature and expand it to a high
dimensional feature vector with X x
squared X cubed x to the 4th right so
this would be one way of defining a high
dimensional future laughing well another
one could be if you have two features x1
and x2 corresponding to the size of
house in the number of bedrooms and you
can map this to different 5x which may
be x1 x2 x1 times x2 x1 squared x2 x1 x2
squared and so on it kind of a
polynomial set of features or maybe
other set of features as well ok
and what we'll be able to do is work
with feature mappings Phi of X where the
original input X may be 1d or 2d o or
whatever and Phi of X could be you know
a hundred thousand dimensional or
infinite dimensional but we'll be able
to do this very efficiently right oh you
an infinite dimensional okay so guess
we'll get some concrete examples of this
later but I want to give you the overall
recipe and then what we're going to do
is a final way to compute ok of X comma
Z equals Phi of X transpose Phi of Z so
this is called a kernel function and
what we're going to do is we'll see that
there are clever tricks so that you can
compute the inner product between X and
Z even when Phi of X and Phi of Z are
incredibly high dimensional right we'll
see an example of this enough in very
very soon and in step four is replace XZ
in algorithm with K of X Z okay because
if you could do this then what you're
doing is you're running the whole
learning algorithm on this high
dimensional set of features and and the
problem with you know swapping out X for
Phi of X right is that it can be very
computationally expensive if you're
working over a hundred thousand
dimensional feature vectors right I mean
even by today's standards you know a
hundred thousand yes yeah it's not the
biggest I've seen I've seen actually
because I've seen that here are the
convenient features but you've been by
today's standards hundred thousand
features is actually quite a lot and if
you're not King said just a thousand
this is a lot and large number of
features I guess and the problem of
using business is quite computation
expensive to carry around these hundred
thousand or
image the 100 million dimensional future
vectors or whatever but that's what you
would do if you were to swap in Phi of X
you know in the naive straightforward
way for X but what we'll see is that if
you can compute K of X Z then you could
because you've written your whole
algorithm just in terms of inner
products then you don't ever need to
explicitly compute Phi of X so you can
always just compute these kernels
then get to that later I won't go for
some kernels I was talked about by his
Darian spray on Wednesday yeah I think
the no free lunch theorem is a
fascinating theory or concept but I
think that it's been I don't know it's
been less useful actually because I
think we have inductive biases that turn
out to be useful
there's a there's a famous theorem in
learning theory called no free lunch was
like 20 years ago dad basically says
that in the worst case learning
algorithms do not work for any learning
algorithm I can come up with some data
distribution so that your learning
algorithm stops that that's roughly the
no free lunch to ever improved about
like 20 years ago but it turns out most
of the world most the time the universe
is not that hostile to all that so so
yeah that's the learning I was turned
out okay all right let's go through one
example of kernels so for this example
let's say that your original input
features was three dimensional X 1 X 2 X
3 and let's say I'm gonna choose the
feature mapping Phi of X to be all so
pairwise monomial terms so I'm gonna
choose X 1 times X 1 X 1 X 2 X 1 X 3 X 2
X 1 okay and there are a couple
duplicates that X 1 X 3 is equal to X 3
X 1 but agenda writes it out this way
and so notice that if you have if X is
in RN right then Phi of X is in R and
squared right so the three-dimensional
features two non dimensional and I'm
using small numbers for illustration in
practice think of X as a thousand
dimensional and so this is now a million
well think of this as maybe ten thousand
and this is now like a hundred million
okay so and squid features this much
bigger and then similarly Phi of Z is
going to be Z 1 z 1 z 1 z 2
some have gone from n features like
10,000 features to n square features HP
in this case hundred million features um
so because there are n squared elements
right you would need order N squared
time to compute Phi of X or to compute
Phi of X transpose Phi of Z explicitly
right say we want to compute the inner
product between 5s and Phi of Z and they
do it explicitly in the obvious way
they'll take N squared time to just
compute all of these in their products
and then do the right and then compute
this uh compute this right and there's
actually n squared over 2 because a lot
of these things are duplicated but
that's the order N squared
but let's see you can find a better way
to do that so what we want is to write
out the kernel of X comma Z so this Phi
of X transpose Phi of Z right and what
I'm gonna prove is that this can be
computed as X transpose Z squared and
the cool thing is that remember X is n
dimensional Z is n dimensional so X
transpose Z squared this is an order n
time computation right because taking X
transpose Z you know that's just in a
product of two n dimensional vectors and
then you take that number you a
transpose Z is a real number and you
just square that number so that's the
order n time computation and so let me
just prove that X transpose Z is equal
to well let me let me let me prove this
step right and so X transpose e squared
that's equal to right so this is X
transpose Z right and then times this is
also X transpose e so this formula is X
transpose e squared is X transpose e
times itself and then if I rearrange
sums this is equal to sum from I equals
1 through n sum from J equals 1 through
n X i zi x j zj and this in turn is you
know some of i sum over J of X I XJ
times Zi
zj and so what this is doing is this
marching through all possible pairs of
inj and multiplying X I XJ with the
corresponding Zi Zi J and having that up
but of course if you were to compute Phi
of X transpose Phi of Z what you do is
you take this and multiply it with that
and then add it to the sum then take
this and multiply with that and add it
to some and so on until you end up
taking this and multiplying that and
having it to your son right so that's
why so that's why this formula is just
you know marching down these two lists
and multiplying multiplying multiply and
add it up which is exactly Phi transpose
which is exactly the Phi of X transpose
Phi of Z okay so this proves that you've
turned what was previously an order N
squared time calculation and turn order
n time calculation which means that if n
was 10,000 instead of needing to
manipulate a hundred thousand
dimensional vectors to come up with
these URLs as my phone buzzing axes
really loud okay instead of needing to
manipulate so 100,000 dimensional
vectors you could do so in the plating
only 10,000 initial vectors now a few
other examples of kernels
it turns out that if you choose this
current so let's see we had K of X comma
Z equals X transpose e squared and we
now add a plus C there where C is a
constant so C is just some fixed real
number that corresponds to modifying
your pictures as follows where instead
of justice
you know binomial terms pairs of these
things if you add plus C there it
corresponds to adding x1 x2 x3 to this
to your set of features technically
there's actually waiting on this and
actually root to see look to see root 2
C and then as a constant C here as well
you can prove this yourself and it turns
out that if this is your new definition
for Phi of X and make the same change to
Phi of Z you know it's a root 2 C Z 1
and so on then if you take the inner
product of these then it can be computed
as this right and so that's and so the
row of the constant C it trades off the
relative weighting between the binomial
terms though you know xixj compared to
the to the single to the first degree
terms like x1 or x2 or x3 other examples
if you choose this ^ d notice that this
still is in order n time computation
right x transpose e takes all the end
time you add a number to it then you
take this the power of G so you can
compute this in all the end time but
this corresponds to now apply of X as
all the number of terms turns out to be
M plus D choose D but it doesn't matter
it turns out this contains all features
of monomials
up to order d so by which I mean it if
let's say D is equal to five right then
this contains then Phi of X contains all
the features of the form X 1 X 2 X 5 X
17 X 29 right this is a fifth-degree
thing or X or X 1 X 2 squared X 3 X you
know 18 this is also fifth order
polynomial fit for the monomials called
and so if you choose this as your kernel
this corresponds to constructing Phi of
X to contain all of these features and
there are exponentially many of them
right there all of these features any
older although these are called
monomials basically all the polynomial
terms all the more narrow terms up to a
fifth degree polynomial up to a fifth
order monomial term so and there are
turns out there are n plus d choose DS
which is a roughly M plus D to the power
of the very roughly so this is a very
very large number of features but your
computation doesn't blow up
exponentially even as D increases so
what the support vector machine is is
taking the optimal margin classifier
that we derived earlier and applying the
kernel trick to it in which we already
had D so well so okto margin classifier
plus the kernel trick right that is the
support vector machine
and so if you choose some of these
kernels for example then you could run
an SVM in these very very high
dimensional feature spaces in these you
know hundred trillion dimensional
feature spaces but your computational
timescales only linearly as all their n
as the number as the dimension of your
input features X rather than as a
function of this hundred trillion
dimensional feature space you're
actually building a linear classifier so
um why is this a good idea
let me just not show a quick video to
give you intuition for what this is
doing let's see okay I think projects it
takes a while to warm up does it any
questions while we're
yes so this kind of function appears
applies only to this vision happy so
each kernel function of yes up to
trivial differences right if you have a
feature mapping where the features that
come you are permuted or something then
the kernel function stays the same so
there are trivial function
transformations like that but if you
have a totally different feature mapping
you would expect to need a totally
different kernel function so I wanted to
let's see oh cool so I want to give you
a visual picture
I've wiped this
all right this is a YouTube video that
can cotton faroush would teach us to
that cs2 there the environment such as
IU so I don't know who Rudy are
erroneous but there's a nice
visualization of what a support vector
machine is doing so let's say you have a
learning algorithm where you're trying
to separate the blue dots from the red
dots right so the blue and the red dots
can't be separated by a straight line
but you put them on the plane and you
use a feature mapping Phi to throw these
points into much high dimensional space
so it's now throwing these points in the
3-dimensional space in this three
dimensional space you can then find W so
W is now three dimensional because apply
the optimal margin classifier in this
three dimensional space that separates
the blue dots and the red dots and if
you now you know examine what this is
doing back in the original space then
your linear classifier actually defines
that elliptical decision boundary
variance right so you're taking the data
all right so taking the data mapping
it's a much higher dimensional feature
space three dimension in this
visualization but in practice can be 100
trillion dimensions and then finding a
linear decision boundary in that hundred
trillion dimensional space which is
going to be a hyperplane like a like a
straight you know like a plane or a
straight line or a plane and then when
you look at what you just did in the
original feature space you found it very
non linear this is your value so this is
y and again you know you can only
visualize relatively low dimensional
future spaces even even on a display
like that but you find that if you use a
SVM kernel
all right you can learn very nonlinear
decision boundaries like that but that
is a linear decision boundary in a very
high dimensional space but when you
project it back down to you know 2d you
end up with a very dominant is about
okay all right oh sure yes so in this
high dimensional space represented by
the feature mapping 5x so this data
always have to be linearly separable so
far been pretending that it does our
coming back and fix that assumption
later today
so um no how do you make kernels right
so just here's something so here's some
intuition you might have about kernels
if X and z are similar you know if - if
- infinite ampuls X is here close to
each other or summit each other then
chain of X Z which is the inner product
between X and Z right presumably this
should be large and conversely if X and
z are dissimilar then KF x z you know
this maybe should be smaller right
because uh the inner product of two very
similar vectors that are pointing in the
same direction should be large and the
inner product of two dissimilar vectors
should be small right so this is one
guiding principle behind you know what
you see in the law of kernels just see
if if this is Phi of X and this is Phi
of Z the inner product is large but then
they kind of point off in random
directions the inner product will be
small right
that's how vector inner product works
and so well what have you just poor
functionality straight out of the air
which is K of X Z equals e to the
negative X is minus Z squared over 2
Sigma squared right so this is one
example of a similar if you think of
kernels there's a similarity measure of
function just you know let's just make
up another similarity measure of
function and this does have the property
that if x and z are very close to each
other then this would be e to the 0
which is about 1 but if x and z are very
far apart then this would be small right
so this function it it actually
satisfies this
criteria satisfies those criteria and
the question is is it okay to use this
as a kernel function so it turns out
that a function like that K of X Z you
can use it as a kernel function only if
there exists some Phi such that K of X Z
equals Phi of X transpose Phi Z right
so we derived the whole algorithm
assuming this to be true and it turns
out if you plug in the kernel function
for which you know this isn't true then
all of the derivation we wrote down
breaks down and the optimization problem
you know can have very strange solutions
right that don't correspond to good
classification that could cost firewalls
and so this puts some constraints on
white kernel functions we could choose
for example one thing it must satisfy is
K of X X which is 5 X transpose Phi of Z
this had better be greater than or equal
to 0 right sorry because in a proper
weight vector with itself had better be
non-negative
so if K of X X is ever 0 or less than 0
then this is the only valid kernel
function okay um
more generally there's a theorem that
proves when is something a valid kernel
somebody just outlined that that proof
very briefly which is let's set X 1 up
to X D you know be any D points and
that's net ok sorry about overloading of
notation this is a so K represents a
kernel function and I'm gonna use K to
represent a kernel matrix as well
sometimes it's also called the grand
matrix but it's called the kernel matrix
so the K IJ is equal to the kernel
function applied to two of those points
xixj right so you have D points so just
apply the kernel function to every pair
of those points and put them in a matrix
and a Big D by D matrix like that so it
turns out that given any vector Z I
think you've seen something similar to
this in problem set one but given any
vector Z Z transpose AZ which is sum of
I sum over j zi k IJ zj right if k is a
valid kernel function so if there is
some feature mapping Phi then this
should equal to sum of i sum of j zi v
of x i transpose Phi of Z XJ times EJ
and by a couple of other steps let's see
this v of x AI transpose 5xj I'm going
to expand out that inner product so sum
of a K Phi of X I element of K times Phi
of XJ other than K times Z J and then
rearranging sums is Sun some of our K
actually sorry I'm running out of white
board and it's still an exploit
several range sums some okay sum of i
sum of a j zi v x phi subscript K times
Phi of X J subscript K times Z J which
is sum of a K squared and therefore this
must be greater than or equal to 0 and
so this proves that the matrix K the
kernel matrix K is positive
semi-definite okay and so more generally
it turns out that this is also a
sufficient condition for a kernel
function since our function K to be a
valid kernel function so I'm just write
this out this is called a vs. theorem so
k is a valid kernel so K is a valid
kernel function ie there exists v such
that K of X Z equals Phi of X transpose
Phi of Z if and only if for any D points
you know x1 up to X D the corresponding
kernel matrix is a positive
semi-definite so let's write this K
trading equals zero and I proved just
one dimension of one one direction of
this implication right this proof
outline here shows that if it is a valid
kernel function then does this positive
semi-definite this Allah did improve the
opposite direction
it's as if an earlier right shows both
direction so this algebra we did just
now proves that dimension of the proof I
did improve the reverse dimension but
this turns out to be a if and only if
condition and so this gives maybe one
test for whether or not something is a
valid kernel function okay and it turns
out that the kernel I wrote up there
that one K of X C it turns out this is a
valid kernel this is called the Gaussian
kernel this is a probably the most
widely use kernel
well actually did what
well actually the most widely-used
kernels is maybe the linear kernel which
just uses K of X Z equals X transpose Z
and so this is using you know Phi of x
equals x right so no no no high
dimensional features so sometimes you
call it the linear kernel it just means
you're not using a high dimensional
feature mapping or the future mapping is
just equal to the original features this
is this is actually pretty commonly used
kernel function you're not taking
advantage of kernels in other words but
after the linear kernel the Gaussian
kernel is probably the most widely used
kernel or the one I wrote out there and
this corresponds to a future dimensional
space that is infinite dimensional right
and this is actually the difficult
kernel function corresponds to using all
monomial features so if you have you
know X 1 and also X 1 X 2 and X 1
squared X 2 then X 1 squared X 5 to the
10 and so on up to you know X 1 to the
10,000 and X 2 to the 17 right whatever
so this the kernel corresponds to using
all these polynomial features without
end going to arbitrarily high
dimensional but giving a smaller waiting
to the very very high dimensional ones
which is why it's why
[Music]
great
so the furniture and then toward the end
I'll give some other examples of kernels
so it turns out that the kernel trick is
more general than the support vector
machine it was really popularized by
this vortex machine where you know
researchers I guess volume of Athens and
Corinth and Cortez found that applying
this kernel tricks the support vector
machine makes for a very effective
learning algorithm but the kernel trick
is actually more general and if you're
any learning algorithm that you can
write in terms of products like this
then you can apply the kernel trick to
it and so you you play of this for a
different learning algorithm in the in
the program assignments as well and the
way to apply the coho Sheikh is take a
learning algorithm write the whole thing
in terms of inner products and then
replace it with okay z it was some
appropriately chosen kernel function k
of XE and all of the discriminative
learning algorithms would learn so far
it can be written in this way so they
can apply the kernel trick so linear
regression which is super aggression
everything that generalizes any model
family the perceptron algorithm all of
the all of those algorithms you can
actually apply the kernel trick to which
means that you can apply linear
regression in an infinite dimensional
feature space if you wish and later in
this class we'll talk about principal
components analysis we should heard of
but when I talk about principal
components analysis turns out that's yet
another algorithm that can be written
only in terms of inner products and so
there's an everyone called kernel pca
kernel principal component analysis if
you don't know how pcs don't worry about
it we'll get to later but lot of
algorithms can be married with the
kernel trick to implicitly apply the
algorithm and even an infinite
dimensional feature space but about
needing your computer to for infinite
amounts of memory or using an infinite
amount of computation but this actually
the single place is most powerfully
apart is that it's the support vector
machine in practice I guess in practice
the kernel trick is apply all the time
in support vector machines and that
often in other algorithms
all right
I shoot any questions
all right so last two things I want to
do today um one is fixed the assumption
that we had made that the data is
linearly separable so you know sometimes
you don't want your learning algorithm
to have zero errors on the training set
right you know so when you take this low
dimensional data and map it's a very
high dimensional feature space the data
does become much more separable but it
turns out that if your data centers will
be noisy right if your data looks like
this you maybe wanted to find a decision
boundary like that and you don't want it
to try so hard to separate every little
example right as to find it really
complicated decision boundary like that
right so sometimes either the low
dimensional space one the high
dimensional space file you don't
actually want the algorithm to separate
out your data perfectly and then
sometimes even in high dimensional
feature space your data may not be
linearly separable you don't want to
algorithm to you know have zero error on
the training set and so um there's an
Aron County or one norm soft margin SVM
which is a modification to the basic
algorithm so the basic algorithm was win
over this subject to
and so what the l1 norm soft margin does
is the following it says you know
previously this is saying that so
remember this is the geometric margin
right if you normalize this by the
normal W becomes excuse me this is the
function of margin if you divide this by
the normal W becomes the geometric
margin so this optimization problem was
saying let's make sure each example has
functional margin created equal to one
and in the unknown soft margin SVM we're
going to relax this we're gonna say that
this needs to be bigger than 1 - see
there's a Greek alphabet see and then
we're gonna modify the cost function as
follows where these C eyes are greater
than or equal to 0 so remember if the
function margin is creating equal zero
it means the algorithm is closed find
that example correctly right if so long
as this thing is getting a little zero
then you know why and this thing will
have the same sign either both positive
or both negative that's what it means by
product of two things to be greater than
zero
both things have to at the same sign
right and so if this is if so so as this
is bigger than zero it means it's closed
find that example correctly and the SVM
is asking for it to not just classify
correctly but classify correctly with a
with a functional margin at least one
and if you allow CI to be positive then
that's relaxing that constraint okay but
you don't want the sea-ice to be too big
which is why you add to the optimization
cost function a cost for making
see I - great and so you optimize this
as function of W and these are the
alphabets and if if you draw a picture
it turns out that in this example with
that being the optimal decision boundary
it turns out that these examples these
three examples will be equidistant from
this straight line right because if they
were then you can fiddle the straight
line to improve the margin you've a
little bit more it turns out that these
three examples have function margin
exactly equal to one at this example
over there we have functional margin
equal to two and the further away
examples that even bigger functional
margins and what this optimization
objective is saying that this is okay if
you have an example here with functional
margin so everything right - the
everything here as function margin one
if an example here I have functional
margin little bit less than 1 and this
by having by setting CI to 0.5 say is
letting me get away with having function
logic loading less than 1
and one other reason why you might want
to use the unknown soft margin SVM is
the following which is that's it you
have a data set that looks like this
you know seems like it seems like that
would be a pretty good decision boundary
but if we add just a lot of examples
there's a lot of evidence but if you
have just one outlier say over here then
technically the data set is still
linearly separable right if you really
want to separate this data set sorry
that seemed to be cooling these pens
myself as well if you want to separate
out this data set you can actually you
know choose that decision boundary but
the basic optimization classifier will
allow the presence of one training
example to cause you to have this
dramatic swing in the position of the
decision boundary so the R because the
original auto margin classifier it
optimizes for the worst case margin the
concept of optimizing for the worst case
margin allows one example by being the
worst case training examples have a huge
impact on your decision boundary and so
the l1 non-stop margin SVM allows the
SVM to still keep the decision boundary
closer to the blue line even when this
one outlier and it makes it so much more
robust to outliers
and then if you go through the
represents a theorem derivation you know
represent w is a function of the alphas
and so on it turns out that the problem
then simplifies to the following so this
is I'm just right after some some after
you know the home represent account the
whole represented calculation the
derivation this is just what we had
previously
I've not changed anything so far right
this is just exactly what we had and it
turns out that the only change to this
is we end up with an additional
condition on the Alpha rise so if you go
for that simplification
now that you've changed the algorithms
of this extra term then the new form
this is called the dual form where they
also say no problem
the only change is that you end up with
this additional condition the
constraints between alpha are between 0
and C and it turns out that today there
are very good you know packages software
packages for just solving that for you
III think once upon a time we were doing
machine learning you need to worry about
whether your köppen inverting matrices
was good enough right and when when Kofa
inverting matrices will as mature
there's just one thing yet to think
about but today linear algebra you know
packages have gotten good enough that
when you invert the matrix it just
invert the matrix you doesn't worry too
much when we're solving you have to
worry too much about it so in the early
days of SVM solving this problem was
really hard you don't worry of your
optimization packages you optimizing it
though I think today they're very good
numeric often
and packages they just solved this
problem for you and you can just call it
with all worrying about the details that
much all right so this l1 no soft margin
SVM and oh and so and so this parameter
C is something you need to choose we'll
talk on Wednesday about how to choose
this parameter but it trades off how
much you want to insist on getting the
training examples right versus you know
saying it's okay if you label if you can
example as well well we'll discuss on
Wednesday we'll discuss PI's and
variants how to choose the parameter
like C all right so the last thing I
want to lastly would like you to see
today there's really just a few examples
of SVM kernels let me just give all
right so it turns out the SVM with
polynomial kernel works quite well so
this is a you know K of X Z equals X
transpose e to the T this is no that's
called a polynomial kernel and this is
called a Gaussian kernel with this video
the most widely used one is a Gaussian
kernel right and turns out that I guess
early days of SVM's you know one of the
proof points as yes was few the machine
learning was doing a lot of work on
handwritten digit classification so
that's a so digit is a matrix of pixels
with values that are you know 0 or 1 or
maybe grayscale values right and say you
take the list of pixel intensity values
and list them so there's 0 0 0 1 1 0 0 0
0 1 0 and just this sound all the pixel
intensity values then this can be your
future x and they feed it to an SVM
using either of these kernels it'll do
not too badly as a pen written digit
classification right so does the classic
data set called m-miss which is a
classic benchmark in computing in
history of machine learning and it was a
very surprising result many years ago
that you know support vector machine
with a kernel
this does very well on hermit integer
classification in the past several years
we found that deep learning algorithms
must be convolutional neural networks do
even better than the SVM but for some
time
lesbians were the best algorithm and and
they're very easy to use in turnkey
there aren't a lot of parameters if they
don't work so that's the one very nice
property about them um but more
generally a lot of the most innovative
work in SVM's
has been into design of kernels so
here's one example let's say you want a
protein sequence classifier so protein
sequences are made up of amino acids so
because a lot of our bodies are made of
proteins and proteins are just sequences
of amino acids and there are 20 amino
acids but in order to simplify the
description and really not worry too
much apology and hope the biologists
don't get mad at me I'm gonna pretend
that 26 amino acids even though they're
because they're 26 alphabets so I'm
gonna use the alphabets A through Z to
denote amino acids even though I know
this suppose me only 20 but this is
easier to talk with with 26 alphabets
and so protein is a sequence of
alphabets right because the protein in
your body is the sequence is made up of
the sequence of amino acids and amino
acids can be very variable 9 something
very very long so if you're very short
so the question is how do you represent
the feature X
so it turns out and so the goal is to be
the input X and make a prediction about
this particular protein like what is the
function of this protein right and so
well here's one way to design a feature
vector which is uh I'm going to list out
all combinations of four amino acids you
can tell this will take a while right go
down to a a a Z and then a a B a and so
on and eventually you know there'll be a
be a JT TST a down to zzzzz right and
then I'm going to construct five x
according to the number of times I see
the sequence in the amino acid so for
example being a JT appears twice so I'm
gonna put two there you know TST a
whatever right a PS ones so I'm for the
one there and there are no a is no ABS
no you see okay so this is a 20 to the
for you know 26 to 420 is a four
dimensional feature vector so this is a
very very high dimensional feature
vector and it turns out that using some
statistical 22 for is 160,000 it's
pretty high dimensional quite expensive
to compute and it turns out that using
dynamic programming given to amino acid
sequences you can compute 5x transyl Phi
of Z as K of X Z and there's a there's a
there's a dynamic programming algorithm
for doing this
the details aren't important for
personal siestas you know if any of you
have taken in advanced years algorithm
schools and learned about the
knuth-morris-pratt algorithm this is
quite similar to that so don new right
with Stanford Stanford professor
emeritus professor here so the DPRK's
question was in ads and using this is
actually quite this is that here pretty
decent algorithm for
sequence of say amino acids and training
a supervised learning algorithm to make
a clock binary classification on
University premises so as your PI
support vector machines one of the
things you see is that depending on the
input data you have there can be
innovative kernels to use in order to
measure the similarity of two amino acid
sequences or the similarity of two of
whatever else and then to use that to
buy the classifier even on very strange
shaped object which you know do not come
as a feature okay so and I think
actually another example or if the input
X is a histogram you know maybe you have
two different countries your histograms
of people's demographic because it turns
out that there is a kernel that taking
the min of the two histograms and then
summing up to compute a kernel function
that inputs two histograms it measures
how similar they are so there many
different kernel functions for many
different unique types of inputs you
might want to possible okay so that's of
SVM's a very useful algorithm and what
we'll do on Wednesday is continue with
more advice on now do you know all of
these learning algorithms we'll talk
about bias and variance to give you more
advice on how to actually apply them so
that's great and then I look hard to see
you on Wednesday